He's the artist formerly known as McLovin.
And after his breakout performance in Superbad,
Christopher Mintz-Plasse seemed like he was
on the verge of joining co-stars Jonah Hill
and Seth Rogen on Hollywood's A-list, following
it up with acclaimed turns in Kick-Ass and
How to Train Your Dragon.
But his popularity with fans somehow didn't
translate into more big time roles.
Here's a look at why Hollywood won't cast
Christopher Mintz-Plasse anymore.
The curse of McLovin
Ever since 2007's Superbad, where he obtained
the world's fakest fake ID, Christopher Mintz-Plasse
has been better known by another name:
"McLovin?"
"Yeah."
"McLovin?
What kind of stupid name is that, Fogel?
What, are you trying to be an Irish R&B singer?"
Nearly ten years later, it's still by far
his most memorable role — which is fine
if you want to be a cult figure forever, but
not so great for the establishment of a robust
and continuing career in Hollywood.
The legacy of McLovin has utterly overshadowed
literally every movie Mintz-Plasse has made
since.
It's a fair bet that at least half his fans
don't even recognize him by his real name.
Turns out that fake ID wasn't so fake after
all.
He's focused on his music
While Christopher Mintz-Plasse definitely
enjoys acting, he's also a dedicated musician,
and his projects on that front are clearly
just as important to him as being on-screen.
He's spending a lot of time these days practicing,
performing, and recording with his latest
band, Mainman — which is, of course, time
he's not spending auditioning for more or
bigger roles in blockbuster Hollywood movies.
Which is just how he likes it, telling Stereogum,
"I would love to keep balancing the two.
I think I'm very lucky and grateful for where
I am right now, that I can do both.
Acting, you can work for three months and
not work for six months.
So in that time, I love the momentum of music
and everything that's going on.
The momentum right now is very musical.
I kinda just go with the flow."
Doesn't court celebrity
While his Superbad castmates seem to be constantly
in our faces at every possibly opportunity,
Mintz-Plasse has kept a much lower profile,
with a media presence that leans more towards
photos of him cuddling with dogs than mugging
for the cameras.
While it may keep his name out of the tabloids,
keeping a low profile in Hollywood isn't exactly
the best career move.
When it comes to making movies, out of sight
is definitely out of mind.
Heard but not seen
Christopher Mintz-Plasse has been a go-to
guy for Dreamworks' animation studio ever
since he scored the role of Fishlegs in How
to Train Your Dragon.
In addition to voicing that character through
three films and a TV series, the actor was
also the first call when they needed a villain's
voice for the 2016 Trolls movie.
Sure, it's nice work, but being a voiceover
actor is just another way to be pigeonholed,
something Mintz-Plasse has already had far
too much of.
"The only way I'll ever be happy is by eating
a troll, and that ain't gonna happen thanks
to you!"
Trapped in a sitcom
In May 2012, Mintz-Plasse scored the lead
role in a CBS sitcom called Friend Me.
It seemed like the perfect vehicle to transition
from movies to television, but tragically,
Friend Me creator Alan Kirschenbaum took his
own life before the project premiered, and
CBS decided not only to leave the show out
of their lineup, but not to even air a single
one of the eight episodes already in the can.
The double blow of losing both Kirschenbaum
and the show was hard for Mintz-Plasse to
bounce back from.
But in 2016, he finally landed another leading
sitcom role, alongside Joel McHale and Stephen
Fry on the CBS sitcom The Great Indoors.
Unfortunately, that show has been panned by
critics, and hasn't exactly set the ratings
on fire either.
Rotten Tomatoes described the show as "one
repetitive, formulaic joke," which hardly
seems to suit an actor like Mintz-Plasse,
who thrives playing against type in edgier,
boundary pushing projects.
Hopefully the show gets a lot better before
Mintz-Plasse gets stuck in the downward spiral
of lowbrow sitcoms.
"Check burn!"
He can turn it around
Part of the reason for Christopher Mintz-Plasse's
low visibility in Hollywood is that he seems
to prefer things that way.
But he still has both the chops and the connections
in the industry to make a comeback if he wants
to.
"Hoo-ah!"
"That's Al Pacino!"
"That's not even -- yeah."
So if he ever decides to commit completely
to acting, and to pursuing more screen time
in bigger movies, becoming a star will probably
be as simple as making a few phone calls to
Rogen and the Apatow crew.
"You wanted me to be my own man.
This is what it looks like."
"Alright, alright, I'll make some calls."
"Yes!"
Fingers crossed!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!